There's no stopping Marvel's box office dominance,
with each new hero, star, character, or superteam
adding to the universe's legacy - and behind
the scenes, adding even more unbelievable
stories and coincidences.
But for all its success and seemingly - perfect
planning, the MCU has just as many weird,
or hard to believe secrets that the studio
would rather fans not spend time thinking
about.
Here are 20 Secrets the MCU Doesn't Want You
To Know.
Wolverine’s Cameo
Before the MCU became a blockbuster monster,
the studio was a lot more open to sharing
their universe with the rest of Marvel's heroes
at rival studios.
It's long been rumored that Marvel had considered
having Hugh Jackman appear as his immortal
clawed soldier alongside Cap during World
War 2.
Even if rights meant he couldn't be CALLED
Wolverine, it still would have been an incredible
cameo.
Casting Iron Man
He may have become the face of the Marvel
Universe, but when the role of Iron Man was
being cast, the studio couldn't have been
less convinced Robert Downey Jr. was their
man.
While they would still have preferred Tom
Cruise, director Jon Favreau knew Downey could
pull off a brilliant man who realizes he'd
been wasting his life - since he already had
himself.
JARVIS
After years playing the voice of Tony Stark's
AI JARVIS, fans finally got to see actor Paul
Bettany on screen, as the new Avenger, Vision.
But it was a first for his costars, too.
The actor admitted that he had never worked
with Robert Downey Jr before then, having
spent close to a decade just recording his
lines in a studio after filming had wrapped.
Sam Rockwell’s Role
Iron Man 2 takes a beating from fans, but
not it's villain.
But in a parallel universe, Robert Downey
Jr and Sam Rockwell could have had their roles
reversed.
Rockwell was invited to read for the hero,
and was apparently in the running before Downey
was cast.
His audition clearly impressed, since he was
asked to return for the sequel.
Daredevil’s Powers
Since Daredevil is as serious a Hero as they
come, Marvel doesn't advertise the fact that
the chemicals which gave him his powers also
turned a group of turtles into teenage mutant
ninjas.
That's according to the turtles creators,
who mirrored most of Daredevil's story in
their own, with Splinter a play on Stick (Matt's
mentor) and fighting the veil ninjas of the
Foot, instead of Marvel's Hand.
Hulk’s Origin Story
With the Avengers' success, fans everywhere
are demanding more Hulk - but they almost
had it.
When Edward Norton signed on to play the hero,
he rewrote the script, adding a longer origin
and even more character scenes.
He and the director tried to convince Marvel
that it was the right move, but the studio
thought tighter action was a better move.
Either way, The Avengers gave some credit,
revealing Bruce Banner had attempted suicide
- the very first scene in Norton's screenplay.
Iron Man’s Price Tag
Cap was a hit, but when The Avengers came
along, Iron Man was Marvel's biggest star
- and Robert Downey Jr, and his agent, knew
it.
With just two movies under his belt, the actor
negotiated a $50 Million paycheck for the
team up, and Marvel had no choice but to pay.
Since the movie made over a billion dollars,
it was more than worth it.
Robert Banner?
He goes by Bruce, but officially, the Hulk's
alter ego is named Dr. Robert Bruce Banner.
Why does he go by his middle name?
Easy: writer Stan Lee forgot which one to
use.
The three part name was his cover story, but
the Marvel legend later admitted he went months
referring to Banner as Bob, before realizing
his mistake.
Casting The God Of Thunder
When Marvel was looking to cast it's riskiest
Avenger, the god of Thunder, it came down
to three actors: Tom Hiddleston, Chris Hemsworth,
and his brother, Liam.
Hiddleston got Loki and Chris got the lead,
but weirdly enough, he found out he got the
role while on the set of Cabin in the Woods,
with his future Avengers director, Joss Whedon.
Just days before, Whedon had actually claimed
he'd make a perfect Captain America.
Odin’s Secret
The Dark World offered one of the first lessons
in the Infinity Stones of the MCU, courtesy
of Odin, Thor's dad.
But the Allfather was apparently keeping some
secrets.
According to Thor director Kenneth Brannagh,
it was Odin who put the MCU in motion, hiding
the Tesseract in Captain America, the Infinity
Gauntlet, and so on.
Whether the current writers agree...
We'll have to wait and see.
Human Torch Costume
The mannequin wearing the original Human Torch
costume in Captain America's opening scenes
is usually taken as a playful jab at star
Chris Evans' former role - but the truth is
even crazier.
The red suited Torch was actually the first
Marvel superhero, whose name and powers were
later recycled for the Fantastic Four - exactly
like Evans, whose likeness and star quality
got him recycled into the Avengers.
What are the odds?
The Hulk Re-casting
When the role of Bruce Banner had to be recast
for The Avengers, director Joss Whedon thought
Marvel would have doubts about his top pick,
Mark Ruffalo, since he wasn't exactly an A-Lister
at the time.
To his surprise, he was Marvel's top pick
too, after he'd been on the shortlist before
Ed Norton landed the part.
Considering how that story played out, they
probably wished they'd made that choice years
earlier.
Post-Credit Secrets
Marvel is famous for its post credits scenes,
but they're not always easy to film, especially
if they haven't been written until after shooting
is finished.
For Thor 2, Natalie Portman wasn't even available
to film her post credits kiss as Dr. Jane
Foster.
Since she was the same size, Chris Hemsworth's
wife, actress Elsa Pataky ("PAD-eck-EE") threw
on a wig and stepped in to take her place.
Department H
The Marvel writers couldn't help but make
reference to the secret Canadian organization
called Department H, mentioned in both The
Winter Soldier and Agents of SHIELD.
There's one problem: thats the experimental
agency that launched the Weapon X program
which created Wolverine and Deadpool in the
comics.
Both characters to which Marvel no longer
holds the rights.
Let's hope Fox didn't notice.
Re-using Locations
The Marvel Universe crosses time and space,
but the actual filming locations can't.
So the studio hopes fans won't look too closely,
or else they'll notice that the centuries-old
village in Thor's prologue is the same one
Red Skull attacks in Captain America.
Or that the secret bunker where Bucky is brainwashed
in the Winter Soldier is the same bank Cap
is blown out of in The Avengers.
Sebastian The Sidekick
Since Captain America has passed his shield
to a few successors in the comics, it's no
surprise that the Marvel films have established
a few candidates in his friends Sam Wilson
and Bucky Barnes.
What fans don't know is that actor Sebastian
Stan was in the running for the role to begin
with, until Chris Evans agreed to sign on,
and Stan got his sidekick instead.
Iron Man’s Suit
It seems like a dream come true to wear the
Iron Man armor, but the reality of a suit
of armor isn't as glamorous.
Thanks to advances in CG, Robert Downey Jr.
only has to wear a headpiece or shoulder pads
on set.
Whenever the iron Avenger's face isn't visible,
fans are actually watching a digital creation,
or a stunt man.
Sorry to burst the bubble.
Laura Haddock
It's an ironclad rule that no actor can play
two different characters in the MCU, with
Paul Bettany's shift from JARVIS to Vision
the only exception.
Well, unless you count actress Laura Haddock,
who appears in Captain America looking for
an autograph... and again, as Peter Quill's
dying mother.
The studio has denied any connection between
the roles, making her casting... impossible
to explain.
Guardians On A Budget
Guardians of the Galaxy turned out to be one
of Marvel's biggest hits - but they didn't
expect it to be.
In fact, the studio only agreed to pay for
the movie's massive prison set to be built
once a plan was set to melt down the steel
after filming wrapped, so it could be sold
for scrap to gain back the money spent.
We doubt that will be a problem for the sequel.
Casting Cap
These days, almost every young actor is fighting
to play a superhero and hit blockbuster level.
But when Marvel sought out actor Chris Evans
to play Captain America, he wasn't sold.
With terrible memories of his Fantastic Four
contract, Evans actually turned Marvel down
- THREE times.
He finally agreed when Marvel dropped his
initial contract from 9 movies to 6, and the
rest is history.
Those are just some of the crazy coincidences
that hide below the surface of the MCU, and
with the movie universe growing by the day,
the list is only going to get longer.
Which Marvel secrets have we missed?
Let us know some of your favorite insider
details, and remember to subscribe to our
channel for more videos like this one.